Kim Rhode: Shooting sports were something that were
passed down traditionally my family.
My grandfather was a houndsman and he taught
my dad and my dad taught my mom and
before I knew what I was going to my
first Olympics and walked away with a
gold medal. Now I look back, six
Olympics later, and I'm still going strong
Hillsdale I've heard through the
grapevine, through various people. It's just
been really this fantastic place where
people are very like-minded, very much
about the Constitution, very much about
Second Amendment, and very much about
shooting and heritage sports. The shooting
sports facility is gorgeous. One of the
things that really struck me because I
think coming from LA we don't have all
the openness, and how open it is, how
beautiful and how well maintained, as
well as the facility itself and all the
different things that they offer in the
forms of shooting--from sporting clays
to five stand, to skeet, to bunker. I mean,
it really is impressive. I have to say I
am blown away not only at the facility
but what they're doing here and the
future that they're making for the
shooting sports and for the kids.